but we had a comment that came in that
said well that's easy for this person to
say because this person is a
professional screenwriter and it's their
job to write all day it makes sense to
say it's your job kind of like get over
it just do it but most people that watch
the film courage channel with you it's
very nice that they thought that are not
professional screenwriters they actually
have jobs sure other jobs have to pay
the bills screenwriting is a hobby for
them at best while they sort of make the
two worlds work sure and that I get so
no you don't have to write every day to
be a writer I don't write every day I do
when I'm on assignment and then when I'm
not I'm kind of exhausted and the last
year has been crazy I mean with like six
movies so it's like almost every three
months to turn around so I'm calm but
it's fantastic because I was constantly
writing but it's it's it's draining it's
almost like I want to go do something
else and stop and they said well when
you stop the assignment I want to go
work on your specs like not right now
because I don't have the time you know
and and but you have to manage your time
you know you really do and there's no
excuse I've had to do it when I was in
college in film school I was working
four to five nights a week in a
restaurant but I had friends who went to
film school or any college and they
could just go to school they had the
luxury of living at home their parents
paid for everything I had pay my bills
you know but I think that that trained
me into really sectioning my time not
just you know because yeah you can go to
parties and all this stuff and I was not
only making movies in the film school
but I was also after day class I had to
go down I was working in Westwood here
and work a five hour shift and then come
home so really trained me for that and
there's a million excuses why we don't
want to write I mean truthfully it's and
when it's difficult even more oh well
you know like I said I never have the
house is never as clean as when I'm you
know procrastination but you know again
the movie I just turned in last week on
assignments my 35th screenplay it's
still learning I still respect the craft
and bow down to
because I learned something every time
out every projects different every
producer company you work with it's a
whole different scenario each time yes
you know you know how it works a lot
better I look at old scripts now and
like my fourth spec my fifth one sold
the fourth one made some noise we met
with the a-list you know actor about it
there's a million years ago but I look
back at that script and I was like ah if
we'd only if I could only go back and
rewrite that with what I know now but
you only have the knowledge that you
have at this exact moment in time and
you can't live with regrets so study get
better write more screenplays
but yes writers right but I don't think
you should feel guilty if you're not you
know writing every day but don't let it
go two days because two leads to four or
four leads two week this weekend we got
something going on you have to schedule
it and I always say to aspiring
screenwriters treat it like your job
because it will be you don't have the
luxury of when you write your specs to
go uh I'm gonna go off today work on it
for five minutes ten minutes whatever it
is but that constant is what's gonna
happen when you get the assignment jobs
and you know you don't want to be
shocked when suddenly you get this
opportunity you're hired to write a
movie and you can't physically sit there
for eight hours a day or you can't write
it in 30 days or you can't write it in
eight weeks or however much time you've
agreed to write the screenplay you will
be shocked because you're not training
the same thing as an athlete or you
wouldn't you wouldn't go run a marathon
without training for it same thing and
in my opinion in my experience and so if
you're gonna spend the time writing your
specs train yourself now for the the
hopefully hopefully the time that you're
going to be hired to write screenplays
and then you'll be much better but again
yes you know coming from a thing that
that's all I do for a living but that's
where you want to be and and like I say
I better I better damn well be doing it
you know ten hours a day if that's all I
do and it seems like maybe some
jobs are more draining than others and I
know it's easy for me to just say oh
well just find a job that's not draining
and I know that's easier said than done
but I think there's certain jobs where
you can then have the sort of a side
other job or slash hobby and then
there's other jobs where it just takes
you out of it it's so demanding and the
thing about that is it's gonna take you
that much longer if you could only write
on the weekends how long do you think a
screenplay is gonna take it's gonna take
six months you know I mean that's where
the time creeps in and there's so many
other distractions and interruptions
that come in that six months that are
dangerous that will derail you so
quickly and then go hmm you know that's
where that's where you have to do I I
would dig deep and say this is what I
want to do and there's nothing I mean
that's sort of the passion and the
tenacity come from that really drives
you through all those other you know
through the minefield you're gonna step
on that pool you know that set you back
three months you know it's really um
it's difficult and yes you're right
other job when I worked at the law firm
for two years
it was draining and I would come home
and then have to write again but I had I
had a move and it was even worse because
I had a movie go into production while I
was at the job and again it wasn't
enough money to quit and so I said I had
to excuse myself and say I'm gonna go to
the set for a few days this week because
I was a as needed assistant type of
position and that was again even years
later a freaky thing going but why do I
have to work at the thing I got a movie
in then you look at the you know okay I
get it and then I stayed on it for
another year at the firm and do the same
thing come home make dinner right you
know blah blah blah and then I got a
call from the production company had
worked with they have a new president of
production and they said hey how come we
haven't worked with you since the last
movie I said I don't know they said we
have this fast track movie we want you
to write it's a it's a done deal and I
gave my two-week notice Wow I was like
this is my kick in my pants that I'm
back in without fear not like oh well
and the money was good
the firm you know but I was seeing
myself be derailed and I had a
relationship at the time my girlfriend
and I saw just everything was being
derailed and I thought well I could just
get into this and you know another year
go by and so when that call came in from
the company I was like I gotta go and
they were shocked they're like well well
I guess this is what you do I said yeah
this is what I do I'm a writer I have to
go do writing and it's a job so yeah I
said you're always welcome to come back
I said exactly but like when I finally
quit the restaurant business when I got
my first job it took six years out of
film school before I landed my first
professional writing job and I thought
when they handed out the diplomas they
were gonna give me a to picture deal you
know oh thank you very much oh look at
this six years and that's not for lack
of writing and specs and all that stuff
a funny landed a job so I gave the
notice at the restaurant and they were
like huh they didn't quite understand
and they were like so and how long is
this job for I go no I'm out o UT not
coming back I said I appreciate there's
never again while I step foot and I
didn't I mean I did catering but that
was sort of like less of a you know your
different places but I was never gonna
work I worked ten years in a restaurant
I did many odd jobs in my life I say in
the book many different jobs that you
have to but it was all about
facilitating me being able to stick with
my dream whatever whatever the job was
at law as long as it allowed me to
continue I didn't care you know it
wasn't embarrassing or you know it was
just like you have to do what you have
to do we might see the movie I just
watched It's a Wonderful Life
so Jimmy Stewart just gets he just
thinks I'm gonna you know go off and see
the world and then go be an architect
and then get sucked back in for two
years or four years at the bank and you
know you know and it just it keeps life
changed for him it's hard you know it
really is hard yeah
but I as I say it's hard I'm living
proof that it does happen and there's no
guarantees but I always say the only
guarantee in screenwriting is that you
should stop writing
you're definitely guaranteed never to
have any chance at success so as long as
you're in the game you have a shot
you